the fate of the universe lies in your  shoulders now whatever you do don't push  this but that was let off the bomb  immediately and we'll all be dead now  repeat back what I just said Congress No  now that's the button of them kill  everyone try again  Congress mm-hmm oh good  uh-huh No  show time a holds up  Oh  [Music]  oh you face  does anybody have any paper out there I  wanna put some paper over the desk but  nobody has anything not a single part  that has tape you have an atomic bomb in  your bag if anybody's gonna have baby  skills I have to do that's a really bad  sign  you may catch someone I can feel their  feeling yeah yeah yeah I guess the  actual ageneral unselfish love forget  about it  actually no no I don't know haha for  everyone  your deepest darkest secret dude come on  you're overreacting a little  you must be so it does hahahahaha just  maybe don't instantly  you